I wonder if you'd believe this as a
solution to the Aboriginal problem heard
the worst of the Aborigines into one
area and put a chemical in their water
that sent them sterile in time there'd
be none of them left well that solution
has been put forward by none other than
one of the premier's closest friends
West Australian mining magnate Lang
Hancock
those would have been assimilated into
you know earning good living learning
wages amongst the Civilized areas that
have been accepted into society and they
have accepted society and can handle
Society I'd leave them well alone
the ones that are no good to themselves
and can't accept things the half cast
and this is where most of the Trouble
Comes I would doubt the water up so that
they were sterile and would breed
themselves out in the future and that
would solve the problem
we rounded people up into our own
concentration camps in fact what we have
done from the original Invasion to now
is constantly reduce Aboriginal people
to a sub-human status
policy says
you're a black Aboriginal Australian
you're not wanted on this Earth
this is Sydney Jewel of Australia and
the good life
I'm on my way to Palm Beach to meet
Diana Edwards who manages Holiday Homes
overlooking the Pacific
oh that's impressive isn't it beautiful
it's like been on a ship and all of that
is Palm Beach yep that's that is the
Pacific Ocean at its best people sort of
are always popping in for drinks so two
levels of entertaining which is fabulous
with a huge big decks yeah what is this
rent for now
um Christmas time about thirty thousand
dollars Australian per week a week yeah
per week that's a lot of money it is it
is but it's um the peak time when
everybody is here
absolute
Paradise found I finally found it yeah
I mean the people ever say to you look
30 or 40 000 a week is just too much or
do they say that's fine no because
obviously you pay for what you get in
life yeah
behind this million dollar view is the
other Australia a secret Battleground
where the first people of Australia
fought the invading British
this was their land which they defended
bravely and with Ingenuity but they had
no guns and were defeated
in 1838 the Sydney monitor reported
it was resolved to exterminate the whole
race of blacks in that quarter
and this is how many of the survivors
lived today
this is Eric alcadra who works at the
health center in the Aboriginal
community of unbladderwatch some 200
miles from Alice Springs in the Northern
Territory
oh yeah I moved moved in here now it's
here another families living
in one house maybe 20 in one house
15 in another
I'm living outside
do you have a kitchen in your house no
no kitchen yeah I have to make a fire
outside yeah you're gonna fire there
wood wood outside no electricity no
electricity yeah
pick up water yeah I used to tap out
here
and you don't have a shower or anything
like that no shower so it's just that
one outside tap yeah so to wash the kids
they've got to stand out on the tap yeah
get a hose get hose the kids
shouldn't be like this should it
no no it's a rich country
yeah it's rich
for some you have a right to certain
things you're paying your taxes
but I'm living in attention
here you are living with your family
here without a kitchen tap outside no
electricity
just over there there's what they call a
government business manager
and he's got
18 air conditioners
yeah you should have given me one then
[Music]
a city of white was born
with its Gardens of Blues and it's fair
perfumes
[Music]
Australia's creation heart of a Nation
these days
this is Canberra the capital of
Australia it's very quiet with wide
clean streets manicured Lawns excellent
schools
and this is the Australian Parliament
according to a government survey it's
one of the most advantaged places in one
of the wealthiest countries
and this is the suburb of Barton named
after the first Prime Minister of
Australia Edmund Barton whose Act of
parliament in 1901 became known as the
white Australia policy
the doctrine of the equality of man said
Barton was never intended to apply to
those who weren't British
and white skinned
Barton made no mention of a people who
had lived here for thousands of years
the longest human presence on Earth
they were deemed barely human Unworthy
of recognition in the new Suburban
Utopia
they are Australia's Secret
this film is a journey into that secret
country my homeland
people describe not only the uniqueness
of the first Australians but their Trail
of Tears and betrayal and resistance
from one Utopia to another
[Music]
we're about 200 miles from Alice Springs
and heading into the red heart of
Australia it's a region known as utopia
call that by the first white people here
who either had a very acute sense of
irony or were demented by the fury of
the Heat
it hasn't rained for months and it's
extremely dry
in the survey I mentioned at the
beginning of the film
which name Barton and Canberra is the
most advantaged place in Australia the
most privileged place
it also named Utopia has the most
disadvantaged place the poorest place in
Australia
it's the home of the first Australians
[Music]
hey
baby
[Applause]
[Music]
I had arranged to meet David Smith who
runs the clinic in the town of umbleta
Watch
David and his team from the Aboriginal
Health Service do their best helping to
care for communities across the vastness
of utopia and Beyond
people live here because this has been
their Homeland for thousands of years
their spiritual and physical home
and yet they are denied the basic
facilities that white Australia regards
as their right and takes for granted
we're meant to be doing Primary Health
Care when really we haven't got the
basic needs of a human being under under
raptured you know which is uh sanitation
water shelter they're out here they've
got no we don't have public transport so
if you don't have a car you're trapped
out here so that's impacting as well
there's no Bush bus service
the essence of us being sharing this
planet together and having some equality
of Life the these toilets being blocked
of course that's going to have a mass
flow on effect you know by
cross-contamination with the hand
washing just in general you know and if
you haven't got water and you haven't
got light well what's going on
Mary I'm just going to show John this
toilet here is that okay
show him what's going on in here this is
an overflow toilet uh John obviously
with a lot of uh rusted out underneath
tin there and obviously it's going to
attract uh snakes and other Vermin into
here and uh
this toilet here is obviously a going
concern of what's been happening here at
uh you know I don't know we can tell
that we don't have a functioning toilet
you think there would be a bison in here
so that kids can wash their hands we've
got a mirror so they can check that
their eyes trichoma you know we've got
ongoing issues cross-contamination of
gastroenteritis
um oh just so many numerous things that
this can create I mean where do I stop
it's you know these are compacting let
alone on the diabetic and the chronic
diseases
we know that there's a major problem
with diabetes we know there's a major
problem with renal and coronary disease
but what we haven't started addressing
is the impacts that low quality housing
and poor maintenance and sanitary
practice is impacting on an Aboriginal
loss all this needs no revamping yeah
it's pulling down and billing again well
it's not a refurbishment is it no no
do you get a lot of cockroaches and that
um yeah because they came out and
sprayed not that long ago didn't they
I've had to get them out of their ears
they've crawled into their ears and I've
shown other health workers they didn't
believe me I said now you need to have a
look at this and look in the air with a
um
otoscope and seeing a cockroach with his
legs and all intact curled up in an ear
and it's in it you know in adults as
well as children's ears in the canal
so I know that they're there so you
can't tell me that there's not
cockroaches and it's not a problem two
talking about ears to a lot of these
children have blue ears that is I use
media blocker
Otis media is a compounding Factor
um in in indigenous people what's the
what's the effect of that well it's a
learning process a delay delay learning
due to the not hearing correctly I can't
hear the teacher no that's right we're
going to get a lot of a lot of problems
we'll get it respiratory normally uh
we'll get uh
cross-contamination
diarrhea gastroenteritis
and how does it affect the young
children particularly well hydration
levels you know you you lose you know
they lose 10 percent
of their body of their body fluids um
we've got some serious problems
these conditions Bear a striking
similarity to communities I filmed 28
years ago
this is all footage but it could be
today
across remote black Australia little
seems to have changed the same Shacks
the same lack of basic Services the same
diseases like trachoma that causes
blindness and is entirely preventable
I can't believe that I'm actually in one
of the richest countries in the world
and you have people Aboriginal
communities here who are living in
conditions which are really almost
inhuman Aboriginal people are frequently
blind for their poverty while
Australians pretend that governments
have tried to invest in those
intransigent communities and never got
any result the truth is something else
entirely governments do not invest in
remote Aboriginal communities because if
governments do they know they won't be
in government very much longer
I I think it's quite shocking that you
can have this level of poverty and this
level of lack of basic facilities and
one of the richest countries in the
world
Australia can easily resolve the
problems here if you take the Utopia
Community which is where we are the
homelands here the total population is
only one thousand four hundred if you
take the Aboriginal community in the
Northern Territories as a whole you're
not talking about more than 50 000
people or so so to suggest that you know
after decades we can't solve this
problem in a country which is absolutely
not short of resources means that the
problem is somewhere else
Mr Snowden you've been a A Member of
Parliament for the Northern Territory
for a total of 23 years almost a quarter
of a century
a third of the territories people are
Aboriginal
why after all these years
is there unchanging shocking poverty
wherever you look
hard question to answer in short
uh I think they're a combination of
issues one of which is some Legacy
issues which revolve around very poor
government policy for
well 50 years at least I mean I've been
making films on indigenous Australia
for as long as you've been a politician
and to be shocked all over again
is is quite an experience and what
people have told me over the years
our sets of excuses in the context of
Health for which I'm responsible and
have been responsible now for a number
of years three years we've made massive
interventions which will address many of
those issues we've got significant
policies very good policies addressing
chronic disease management these
policies have been introduced by this
government since 2007 and they are
making a significant difference
there was no significant difference for
one Aboriginal man who died during the
night I was staying in his community
the next morning his family and his
small tin Shack were gone
when an Aboriginal person dies their
home dies too
on the night I was there a man called Mr
Davey aged just 47 died of a heart
attack in his humpy about 20 meters from
the clinic they couldn't save him with
all the equipment they had and all their
expertise they had and it was made clear
to me that they couldn't save him
because this man probably had as a child
rheumatic heart disease which is the
highest recorder has the highest
recorded rate in the world which is why
we're investing in the primary health
care to try and ensure that these young
kids the next generation of kids don't
have their father's problems and that's
what we're doing and I'm proud of what
we're doing well I'm glad you're proud I
just couldn't see evidence well beginner
thing of in these in these days you
talked to the doctors ring the doctor's
up after yes I've talked to them
one doctor doctor one doctor I talked to
she I didn't expect her to say what she
said she compared the conditions with
19th century dickensian England she said
in that time there was rheumatic heart
disease that's right I talked to another
Doctor Who reminded reminded me that
Australia is on a United Nations
Shameless as having not conquered
trachoma which even poor countries like
Sri Lanka and did she tell you about the
Investments we're making in trachoma
right now I'm not proud of the past I'm
certainly not proud of the past what
about the person what I am proud of is
you're proud of the president I'm proud
of the fact that how could any how could
any Australian and I'm in Australia walk
into those beginning to say their
prayers do let me finish
I'm proud of the response this
government's made to what is a very poor
set of circumstances for Aboriginal
people not only there but in other
communities across this country and I
won't have it from you that we're not
committed to doing making those changes
and I won't have it from you that we're
not investing those resources
Mr Snowden for two reasons one you're
the minister of indigenous health and
two you've been the representative of
some of the poorest sickest people in
Australia for 23 years why haven't you
fixed it
um what a stupid question what a stupid
question what a plural question
sometimes in my darker moments I
actually think that addressing the
indigenous development problem in
Australia is beyond the capacity of
Australia
and that we actually need
overseas aid in addressing this problem
we need we need people from outside
Australia to come in and tell us how do
we deal with this problem it's become so
politicized and acerbic here that we
just cannot uh deal with it rationally
[Music]
no one nine was a young man
and I let the free life
[Music]
from the Murray's green bison to the
dusty Outback well I Waltz mine till the
all over
here as you enter the Australian war
memorial in Canberra Aboriginal people
are represented alongside wild animals
reptiles and birds
in a country of cinetovs commemorating
Foreign Wars not one stands for those
who fought and died resisting the
invasion of their own country
Australia
is there any commemoration Remembrance
in the museum about the frontier Wars
the wars fought against that Invasion no
why is that I don't know
that was a major war isn't it I don't
know I mean listening to you I'm
surprised you have such a
very interesting and a very
enlightened view frankly of so many wars
and yet we have yes no commemoration I
said I served with indigenous soldiers
and they're wonderful people and I had
great admiration for what they did and I
know how they suffered but I really
don't know why we don't Embrace that
history maybe we're maybe we're not
overly proud of that history
thank you
official them in Australia is so
sensitive to this truth that I was
refused permission to film in this great
public place
and had to play tourists with a camera
[Music]
walls
my first encounter with Aboriginal
people was here at La perouse
overlooking Botany Bay where Captain
Cook landed
I was 11 years old
and it was an adventure to sit on the
sand dunes and look at the people who
lived in Shacks who were meant to be
dying off
Aboriginal people were not counted in
the senses unlike the Sheep
a school textbook explained why
we are civilized and they are not
this is a TV documentary from 1962 that
captures the mood of the time as if
Aborigines were not Australians at all
an attitude that seems to have barely
changed
do you regard yourself as dark and your
people as dark people
oh yes my father was a full blood and my
mother's fear or take after my mother
but I don't class myself any better or
any lower than anybody else I I just
class myself on it on the level of
everybody else why do you think that you
live the way that you do oh well see
this place here that they haven't done
it up but they pay rent people pay rent
here but the prices are not up to
standard some of them could pass easier
for us dragons
few of them care to talk about their
disappointments have you ever taken any
interest in this whole problem yourself
yes before years ago why did it I was
fighting for child endowment bonuses
I'm against the way the papers they
incriminate my people they'd ring us
down they don't try to lift us at all
they forget we're human
denigrating their Humanity was part of
an ideological campaign known as the
history Wars
following the election of the
conservative John Howard in the 1990s a
group of academics and commentators
claimed there'd be no invasion of
Australia no massacres no genocide
foreign the arrival of the British was a
day of celebration for which the natives
should be grateful
they and their culture were all but
obsolete
their history worthless
genocide denial was the propaganda of
Empire trying yet again to justify the
stealing of land and the banishment of
its people
it's Australia Day 2013
celebrating the founding of Australia
has a penal colony in 1788
the convicts were the poor British and
Irish
for Aborigines this is survival day a
day of mourning
what's Australia Today mean to you just
a big celebration on all our
country do you think the first
Australians have a role in Australia Day
are they many of them are rather
offended by it are they why well because
that's the day 225 years ago that we
took their country
as all we all think of them anyway too
that's why we all celebrate do you think
they have a special place so as it was
their country for thousands of years
they could have their special place but
now it's everyone's place
they still live in very poor conditions
most of them oh suppose that's there for
all day if they're part of our society
too they have to do the same as us and
try and help things when they can get
work thanks
to to be one of us I know it's hard for
them because nobody wants to employ them
they say it's their country when you say
one of us they would say well maybe it's
the other way around yes
this is ours I know that that's what
makes it hard doesn't it well over
history that's always happened isn't it
from the original yeah the yeah this is
only through the media that I've heard
where they're drunk and they can't get
up and they don't want to help
themselves you know we'll
that's that's no good either is it you
know you've got to try and get them
sober save them up and say well you know
you can have a future
living in such shocking conditions still
there well I think that's what they want
they get offered a lot of things but
that's what they want you think they get
off a lot yes I've been into Central
Australia and all that and yeah yeah I
think that's just how they like to live
they like to live in that in their own
yeah
what about the people whose country it
was in the beginning what about them
they've got much to celebrate today have
they no they do what because you come to
this country mate you're a part of this
country oh they didn't come to this
country they were here to begin with
they had it they're all strange of years
they're all Australia everybody that
comes with this country is Australian
why do you think they find today a day
of mourning a day of offensive day
because it celebrates
I do not believe that was an offensive
we are all Australians
every single person walking past me
right here yeah everybody yeah the
Aussie
it doesn't matter if they're black white
yellow blue green whatever man yeah
they're Rossi we're on Australian
are you Australian no you're not Irish
how do you think the first Australians
make up today because they haven't got a
lot to celebrate have they the
Aboriginal people
in my way well uh 225 years ago uh their
country was taken from see you later
you're full of [__]
the fact remains
that we've never left this country
we have never
seated any part of our country or signed
that over
to any other foreign
settlers that's Australian
we've never done that none of our people
have ever agreed
to say Rada you can take my country
but in exchange for that I want some
welfare funds
our people have never been aware of such
a transaction what amazes me is
there is not the hatred
because that's beneath our dignity to
hate people
um we have not got that
we have not got that anger
but as all people have to start thinking
about
writing the wrong awful wrong
that continues to happen to us and Ours
[Music]
the early birding traffic takes the
Narrows Bridge to Perth
while down the swan at applecross the
boats lie at their birth this was the
official 1960s vision of a Suburban
Utopia in Australia's biggest and
richest state
but it was dependent on airbrushing out
an entire human community
ah this is better than life for me
a day by the beach in the open sea
rottnest Express is the smoothest
fastest ferry service traveling to
rottnest Island what Nest island is
Western Australia's idyllic Island
Getaway I'm traveling to rottnest Island
from Perth
tourists call it rotto from 1838 it was
a brutal prison but ought to be as
notorious as Robben Island in South
Africa
two members of the indigenous nunga
Nation
they know the truth about this island
when I asked Marianne to accompany me
she was fearful until Noel offered to
protect her from the sense of horror and
Injustice that awaited us
rottnest Island was one of the British
Empire's most isolated concentration
camps
part of a genocidal history that's
barely recognized in white Australia
on the beach Noel performs a ceremony
meant to protect us all
so
do you scoop up a bit of sand
and then
finale Wagga like your body odor will be
on the sand and when you throw it out
there the spirit here will know that
you're here what are we in
thank you
father than Indian
on the ferry over I just picked this up
yep and here it is rottnest Island yes
and naively I was waiting for a
description in the historical section of
something yeah not the horrors but even
a sanitized version of the concentration
camp that was here there isn't anything
no historic rottenness here it is play
and stay
make Wonder of rottnest Island and the
harmonious surroundings of names of the
nest Lodge daily ferries and organized
flights can whisk your way to this
paradise in just 30 minutes
this was a prison known as the quad
thousands of Aboriginal men and boys
were incarcerated here many of them
tortured and killed
today it's a hotel with a luxury spa
Australia must be no the only country
that makes a tourist Hotel out of a
place of carnage
I can't think of another one they're the
obvious comparisons yeah but this is
it's so degrading we we feel so
you know so traumatized about all of
this
and uh
you can imagine
seven people living trying to be crammed
into each cell
you know there's three cells here
and the kind of conditions that they
were living in
the the conditions they lived in
initially when this was first built
um
they only had one
vent above the door
that was it
and it gets really cold here and it gets
really hot here this is obviously a
family room this is where the children
go they've got double Bunch
yep parrots there yep
um and you know you know this room we're
in
is actually
um three rooms
in each cell there's three of them here
so nine 17 people died in each cell
17 people so in this expanse you can see
from that wall over there to there 51
people have died
and this is what people now pay 240
dollars yes that's what it costs we
rented this room to do this interview
wow two hundred and forty dollars
unbelievable and they don't have any
idea what happened in here no one tells
them
No One lets them know and I tell you
what if it was me
I would want to know
what happened in the room that I sleep
in
just outside that window that door they
built a Gallows
they hung a gas going man there
and the other prisoners that came down
with him had never seen someone hung
and they were subjected to being lined
up each side of the Gallows
and the prisoners built the Gallows that
had already been here
and they've watched as that man was hung
the impact it had on them
they were just stunned and for days and
days
they were just Mourning
and wouldn't eat
so that's ticking over as well as what
happened here and you know these people
coming in here and staying here this is
what Aboriginal people are subjected to
in Australia The Lucky Country
I mean
lucky for who
certainly not us we're refugees in our
own country
next to the hotel is one of Australia's
largest mass Graves over 300 Aboriginal
prisoners are buried here
until a few years ago there was no sign
indicating this was sacred ground
what was once the morgue is now the
hotel kitchen
the manager of the hotel told me there
were long-term plans to convert the quad
prison to a memorial
you see the burial ground and they just
got no respect at all for for the
history of our people
have all them unmarked Graves with a you
know
a sign talking about the place but then
you've got a road right between her
where the car can drive through and
people can just walk and desecrate the
areas of our ancestors remains
rottnest island is not the past
Western Australia is a state of
imprisonment for black Australians
on Australia Day 2008 an Aboriginal man
called Mr Ward died a terrible death as
he was driven 300 miles in this prison
van in blazing Heat
the temperature in the mobile cell
reached 56 degrees Centigrade the
coroner called it a disgrace
the director of public prosecutions took
two years before deciding to do nothing
eventually the van drivers their
employers and the prisons Department
were fined for a breach of health and
safety regulations
an Aboriginal man called Mr Ward
suffered really terrible death the
coroner said in effect he cooked to
death the coroner
also said that your department when you
were minister
shed the responsibility
for his death I certainly contemplate a
resignation
after it happened because what's the
point in Parliament if you can't change
things for the better
well the Aboriginal
Legal Services yes
they routinely warned you yes as
Minister yes so you couldn't say you
didn't know no I knew and I in fact I
couldn't recall writing a lengthy letter
to the Aboriginal legal service I did so
on the on the basis that the bureaucrat
gave me insurances that they would lift
their game this was an especially
horrific death a man cooked to death he
was so hot that there was a terrible
burn across his body and he died
where does the buck stop ultimately
you're right the buck stops with me
um all the whole justice system uh is to
some extent at fault now I as I said I'm
not evading my role because I'd I regard
myself as at some level being personally
responsible you were in charge of the
department yes I agree entirely and it's
something that I'll go to mcgrave
regretting intensely why didn't you
resign
I contemplated it for three days what
happened and then I thought well
um I really want to see if I can
you know do whatever I can to fix the
issue but what did you do to fix it what
what I did was
um we already had for example other
transport
um
better better style vehicles on order
and so there are things like that that
need change but that doesn't happen to
white people does it no of course not
when was the last time a government
minister in Australia resigned and said
we can't take this kind of atrocious
racism it seems that we're waiting for
the next
case to happen I had to put my staff
through cultural sensitivity training
cultural sensitivity but my staff in my
office
on the pretext so that I could then
invite the senior people from corrective
services along
in the hope that they suddenly suddenly
understood some of these
fundamental issues what what's cultural
sensitivity well well about about our
Aboriginal culture what the issues were
from a corrective Services perspective
so I've suggested my staff who I or who
I thought were excellent in my
ministerial office to this training on
the pretext that I could get some of the
senior managers in from the Department
in to actually learn some basic facts
about
Aboriginal culture so they didn't know
any history they didn't know that
massacres took place across this country
they didn't know that
that people had been sent to a form of
Devil's Island certainly some of them
did there are some very well-meaning
people who do all know that but some of
the Senior Management and in fact one of
the senior managers uh who's a female
she was asked when she joined the
Department here in an interview in the
departmental magazine
um you know what exposure she had to
Aboriginal culture she said she'd come
from Bradford and dealt with a lot of
pakistanis so she understood these
issues
how was she planning to deal with
Aborigines in Australia well I I just
had no idea it was shortly after that
that I arranged the training session
you arranged the cultural yeah
sensitivity training yeah
is Western Australia building more
prisons
um
at the moment there
[Music]
racking and stacking them as the
vernacular excuse me what is racking and
stacking well they're double bunking
so it literally is warehousing people I
think they're warehousing and racking
and stacking
that's the way they filled up the slave
ships
that that is what they're doing John
they are raking and stacking they've
just built a 14th prison adult prison uh
and and they've lauded it's been
applauded by a lot of people it's up in
Derby and it's an Aboriginal prison so
it's going to be mostly Aboriginal no
it's going to be all Aboriginal from
less than three percent of the
population
this whole notion of the Law and Order
State
um you know increasingly looking
um as some argue to have um you know a
centaur state that looks after
very well those who conform
um and and fit in to um in in terms of
uh you know neoliberal Global values and
incarcerates and and treats very harshly
those who don't conform and I think what
we see in Australia is not just a
punishing of the poor but punishing of
the indigenous different
um these are people who have
fundamentally different norms and
they're very susceptible to not
conforming to the Norms of the Law and
Order state
which again some argue is a direct
product of a global neoliberalism here
where we are in the Northern Territory
the rate of incarceration was six times
that of the incarceration of black
people during the last 10 years of
apartheid in South Africa
in Western Australia it's apparently
eight times more
do you think Australia should be
regarded as an apartheid state I don't
think it's a lot different apart from
the fact that there aren't signs
everywhere saying you know black people
drink from this step and white people
drink from that tab but in in in Alice
Springs alone it you would have to be
blind not to see a part right here the
amount of people are taken into
protective custody is staggering and the
recent death in custody Colonial and
Alice Springs I can't remember the
figures but even after 25 years in the
Northern Territory I was staggered that
I needed that that actually that many
people go into our custody the evidence
is in
all our jails particularly in the
Northern Territory fools were bursting
and it's not going to change anytime
soon we really need to deal with the the
underlying problems and again it's easy
for me to say because I don't have the
answer but we've spoken about it giving
people good housing giving people a good
education
making sure People's Health is looked
after as well as mine and everybody else
is in the community
in 1981 Eddie Murray died in police
custody in the New South Wales town of
we War in spite of evidence of police
lying and cover-up no one was prosecuted
a second inquest found that his sternum
had been smashed
for more than 25 years I followed and
filmed a campaign for Justice by Eddie's
parents Arthur and Leela Murray
I filmed this interview with them in
1987.
in my own mind
I know Eddie he wouldn't have take his
life I think he was killed by it
the police officer
in 2012 Arthur and I went back to We
wore where his family had grown up
and were Eddie had been killed
Arthur Murray's life and extraordinary
achievements are almost unknown in white
Australia
Arthur worked as a chipper weeding the
cotton fields he was paid just over a
dollar an hour
paying black Australians or pittance has
a long history in the land of fair go
it was hard too because we had we had
planes flying over topless when we were
working
pesticides
once they sprayed the cotton you know
they spray YouTube
we had to work under those conditions
until we put a stop to it
Arthur Murray and the cotton chippers
went on strike and hundreds of them
marched through the town
we wanted a bit of working conditions a
better living condition and higher wages
all right arranged to have it the
average people stopped work
not to go on to a cotton wheel
was everyone unanimous on that they all
agreed we stopped work and
we demonstrated
the local newspaper called them
communist troublemakers
Arthur was the best kind of trouble
the cotton chippers won an historic
victory
so we won a battle of three
you want higher wages
living conditions
the council allowed you to Camp here
yeah
so our demands were met
but the Murray Family paid a price
they were harassed and often attacked by
whites leading to the violent death of
Eddie
the white people from other hand didn't
think
it was right for us to live here so they
just come and
Intimidators and harasses
what are your feelings coming back to
wee wall Arthur
Donna it has
it's hard to come back to this place
it's a sense of uh John of losing a boy
you know
people like myself and and other people
that fought for for having a people and
fought for their rights
and fought for better condition fought
for for what
we feel that is what hasn't changed one
bit and I doubt with a with it will
change
you keep you keep asking yourself that
is keep asking themselves a question
over and over
uh we're going to find Justice and we're
going to find
the people that
that recognize that we existed in this
country
one rule for the whites and one reel for
the blacks as far as I'm concerned
I mean the Royal commission said that
the police committed perjury but they
falsified their records
that they lied how many prosecutions
were there nil
the Royal commission came up with
how many recommendations in the end
339 recommendations they've came up with
and there is still nothing's been done
and there are still people dying
in police and prison custody
the day I walked up those steps
into that front door
and I was asked to go upstairs
and to be told that he was dead I
couldn't believe it I still don't
believe it
how do you feel after all these years
what do you want to happen Lily
I want the state government to have a
look at it you know see if we can get
some answers from them
in other words for what they took away
from us
you know son
I've suffered a lot you know over the
years
I don't think I'd take any more
we do dancers don't
when do you think things will ever
change in this country
this country
Leela died in 2004
still fighting for justice
every time you come here is it sadness
and anger or
Donna Smith
the sadness and also anger
ah
and that's how I do
to talk about it but yeah I've got a
express my feelings about a son that I
loved and
I expressed my my anger about
how he died and under those
circumstances and
uh
those anger still are still with me it
it's almost impossible to say that Eddie
foreign
didn't die in vain because it began
a campaign on behalf of so many others
which your T-shirt says and
it's the recognition of that by white
Australia
that can only
redeem
if that's possible
white Australia from its own role in the
deaths of young men like Eddie
recognition of it and that means Justice
doesn't it
for sure I'd mean Justice and
this happened in 1981
and it's 2012. yeah and we are still
waiting yeah for the white man to give
us Justice
and it has to come yet
this is Leila's grave yeah
well she felt John Lewis pain and
can sorrow and
she thought maybe one day that we'll get
Justice
but that's right that has failed us
failed there the final family
how old were you when you met you two
I was 15 little 16 ah 17.
it's two years older than yeah
blue been together for 46 47 years
together
and you brought up a family of
12 children together nine girls three
boys here yeah
a great lady a great woman yeah
I can't say anything better than
that she was a a classic a lovely lady
Arthur Murray's heroic stand for the
cotton workers is part of a hidden
history of Aboriginal resistance
epic victories by Stockman Farm Workers
and their families ended slave labor in
Australia
at wave Hill in the Northern Territory
an historic strike by the garingji
people became a rallying cry for justice
for all black Australians
this movement this strike
was the longest strike in Australia's
history yeah it's eight years and they
were threatened by police
and others who worked on the station
they would have made a stand
against this
and this is one of the most historical
movements in this country
wave Hill was the largest cattle station
in the world owned by the British
multi-millionaire Lord Vesti
Aboriginal people were the backbone of
the cattle industry yet they work for
little or no money and rations
in 1966 led by Vincent lingiari the
workers and their families walked off
their Defiance is expressed by their
Union organizer Dexter Daniels
yes
too long to wait
so you want to break the law in effect
that's right you think you get all the
Aborigines on your side yes
in all the Northern Territory that's
right
I win
I do all I can
every way as I can
I'll bring them
in my ways
this strike was a victory for the
principle of equal pay
and decent working and living conditions
the struggle for land rights is at the
heart of the continuing struggle for
freedom in Australia
black Australians have won limited land
rights and a native title law
but this often gives preference to the
institutions of white power resulting in
bitter divisive battles for sacred land
and the wealth beneath it
[Music]
the Sacred Heart of Aboriginal Australia
is Uluru
where tourists can enjoy the good life
for more than two thousand dollars a
night it's ecosensitive and out of sight
of the poverty and slums of those whose
Land This is
[Music]
the people of mutajulu are the
custodians of The Rock
they're overcrowded houses are riddled
with asbestos which causes cancer
since 2008 the government has built
fewer than a thousand new houses for
Aboriginal people in the Northern
Territory
this is my daughter's house Mary
she lives here with extended family
groups
and 32 people now living in this one 32
people see the community condemned that
house there because the asbestos was all
broken yeah and it was painted over it
was broken so it's going to cause health
problems in the future and so you've had
a lot of that pressure haven't you yes
of people having to move from condemned
houses into houses like this one
so they've done audits of all of moto
Julie the whole Community they've found
asbestos in 70 of the buildings they've
identified it like this yes and yet
they've allowed
people to go on living yes yes because
obviously we've got nowhere else to live
we do not and my main concern because
we've got little kiddies in this comes
through
[Music]
because at the moment we're in Dire
Straits you know you sleep end to end
and end and end like we've done as kids
there's the bathroom yep bathroom and
the toilet there's so many people living
in here you can't renovate an asbestos
house it's got to come down
so there's 20 people living in a house
with one toilet and every time more
people come to stay the sewer floods you
know this raw sewage in the backyard
so you're talking about stronger lordies
sometimes I wonder if I should be
testing people for cholera I'm looking
out for it
has this house had any money at all from
the housing authority to renovate it
people got one cent to repair our houses
the repairs what we do here we go to the
local rubbish dump and we recycle
whatever we can yeah yeah that's the way
that we have to survive here a lot of
young children are here too aren't they
well uh majority of the householder the
primary school children primary school
children
so that in this kind of overcrowding
that cross-infection that all children
are prone to is going to be rampant 70
hearing appear impairment amongst the
little ones just not on
70 ear infection and so they're hearing
partly deaf yeah yes they are my my
daughter here who owns his house is dead
how ironic that my daughter has to put
up
asbestos house with 32 people in
Australians this is why we say an abuse
of Human Rights Australians yeah
there was a report by the indigenous
doctors Association that mentioned the
incidence and degree of malnutrition
starvation oh absolutely
malnourished children
um
people who are overweight who are still
malnourished because they're living
basically on flower and meat which is
subsidized by the council here some of
the money that comes to the community
Through the tourism Venture is used to
subsidize the cost of meat so people get
enough protein but they don't get enough
Vitamins because they don't get fruit
and vegetables because they're too
expensive how many people would have to
sleep in this bed well if you can double
up the kids
hit the foot head to foot head to foot
probably about eight or not
yes then you've got another mattress
with about three or four we sleep in a
single bed
you've had report after report by the
government saying that this the biggest
single cause of poverty among Aboriginal
people is housing
following his apology Kevin Rudd
promised in fact a lot of 700 million
dollars to building housing houses in in
indigenous communities where is it they
had nine brand new vehicles with 11
people in the 90s these are the housing
people they came and ordered it the
community not once seven times
and still the housing condition is still
like this
we we also have extra people living
outside outside here
or family be sleeping family be sitting
there
well I feel sometimes like I'm dealing
with similar conditions to the English
working class in the 1870s where or the
1780s for example where you had 20
people in a room and an open sewer in
the middle of the court and people
dealing with uh
terrible infectious diseases that killed
them early and
addictive behaviors from the
dispossession that the English working
class went through at the beginning of
the Industrial Revolution
in 2007 prime minister John Howard and
his Minister Mal brough declared a state
of emergency in the Northern Territory
but they applied it only to Black
Australians
well ladies and gentlemen Mr Bruff and I
have called this news conference to
announce a number of major measures to
deal with what we can only describe as a
National Emergency in relation to the
abuse of children in indigenous
communities in the Northern Territory
known as the intervention its aim they
said was to save Aboriginal children
from pedophiles
but there was a hidden agenda
it is interventionist
it does push aside the role of the of
the territory to some degree I accept
that but what matters more
the Constitutional niceties or the care
and protection of young children the
intervention was launched
on a very cynical big lie a vicious one
that smeared all Aboriginal people in
the Northern Territory because the
minister for indigenous Affairs at the
time Mel Brook said there were pedophile
rings in all of these communities that
the federal government was going to
occupy an extraordinary sweeping claim
the legislation that delivered the
intervention this Federal takeover
doesn't actually mention children but
the propaganda machine from the
beginning was relentless everybody in
those communities knows who runs the
pedophile Rings they know who brings in
the petrol they know they know who sell
the gunja they need to be taken out of
the community and deal dealt with an
extraordinary sweeping claim if we are
going to be saving the children we
couldn't have any of the recommendations
about talking to the Aboriginal
organizations or Consulting Aboriginal
people or even asking the Aboriginal
families well what is the status of
these children it was time to send in
the troops they scared The Living
Daylights out of everybody it really did
the mothers taught their children was
going to be taken away and they bolted
everybody left this community so they
the Army just rolled in in their trucks
and pitched their tents in the middle of
the community yes yeah right Australian
army yes in an Australian Aboriginal
Community yes all these soldiers we were
being attacked
foreign
for the first time in modern Australia
the Army was sent into black communities
at the spearhead of a government
determined to control people's lives and
their land
fear and shock overwhelmed communities
people who refused to hand over the
lease of their lands were to be denied
basic services like decent housing and
sanitation
a government job scheme that employed
thousands in remote areas was all but
eliminated benefits and pensions were
restricted and people could only buy
Essentials with a special Basics card
only black citizens were treated this
way
as people's incomes were quarantined
starvation was reported the government's
own Review Committee found what it
called a collective despair among
Aboriginal people
the rate of self-harm and attempted
suicide quadrupled
laying the ground for the intervention
was a lurid media campaign led by a
national TV program called late line
[Music]
late line claimed that Aboriginal
children were the victims of sex slavery
the program's allegations centered on
the community of mutter julu a key
witness was this man whose identity was
disguised they called him a former youth
worker
the people who are in control are the
drug dealers and the petrol Warlords and
the pedophiles
there was no sex slavery no petrol
Warlords no pedophile rings
the anonymous witness was actually a
senior government official who had
worked in motor julu but never lived
there
the late line program was exposed by
investigative journalist Chris Graham
founder of the national indigenous times
in 2006 late line began reporting that
sexual abuse in Aboriginal communities
was rampant and that
Aboriginal men were violent and beating
and abusing women and children on a on a
scale that can't be believed and it was
that style of
extraordinary sensationalist reporting
that paved the way for the federal
government to introduce policies that
frankly Australians haven't seen I mean
the anonymous youth worker in fact was
this government official call
Gregory Andrews
and he claimed that he'd actually lived
there for seven months he hadn't lived
there a single night he'd never stayed
overnight in moradulu in his life I've
been told by a number of people of
men in the region who go to other
communities and get young girls and
bring them back to their community and
keep them there as six slaves the
funniest thing was seeing Greg Andrews
or seeing this man in a hat and a jumper
that I knew was his hat and his jumper
and seeing him sitting there talking in
this robotic voice
about stuff that he had known about this
community or seemingly known about this
community and I'm sitting there watching
going is that Greg
and it was and there was and who did you
know Greg to be so Greg Andrews was my
boss in the department in the office of
indigenous policy coordination he was
the assistant secretary the branch
manager so he was a government a senior
government official yes
yes
he made all sorts of bizarre claims he
he made a claim that he knew of or he
had heard of children being held in
communities against their will and
traded amongst communities by Aboriginal
men as sex slaves he claimed that he'd
seen women coming to meetings with
broken arms and screwdrivers and other
implements hanging out of their legs was
there any substance at all in any of
these claims zero I mean none at all
I asked the man in the Hat Gregory
Andrews for an interview but he declined
the minister for indigenous Affairs Mel
Bruff looking at the evidence quote
unquote that the program had produced
about so-called pedophile Rings said the
child abuse was happening in Unthinkable
numbers
extraordinary thing to say wasn't it
extraordinary particularly in the
context that he knew the anonymous
former youth worker on the ABC program
was actually his advisor to me that was
indicative of a complete lack of good
faith in the production of the program
because if they couldn't get
someone more more objective than that
it's it must to those who are making the
program of
made them at least think that there was
a possible problem more than a possible
problem and yet they just went ahead
with it the Australian crime commission
which you set up and gave special powers
to found no evidence the Northern
Territory police found no evidence
umpteen reports since then frankly have
found no evidence well that is I'll reel
them off to you if you'd like feel free
factually incorrect
so what they have found is that the
Australian crime commission were lying
the Northern Territory police had got it
wrong is that it the reality is is that
when they went into these communities
they couldn't find the people that would
substantiate the evidence
they will tell you that there is any
amount of inescapable evidence such as
STD of children at a very young age and
I have personally spoken to parents and
relatives who can identify the
individuals but they won't you accused
Aboriginal communities
and all Aboriginal communities not just
matajulu of harboring pedophile Rings
first of all there was an independent
report put together inquiry put together
by the Northern Territory labor
government they visited 45 distinct
separate Aboriginal communities in the
Northern Territory and they found
evidence of child sexual abuse in every
single Community Mr Bruff totally
completely misrepresented little
children are sacred and used it in a
very crude way to his own ends why would
the minister want to say such a thing
because it's just not true
I don't I don't I don't understand
the report did not point to pedophiles
or pedophile Rings or you know dozens of
people roaming around sort of abusing
children it wasn't that kind of report
at all we wrote what people told us
about and all the concerns that they
have so they spoke to us about poverty
they spoke to us about kids not going to
school young mothers
a lack of education for everybody
lack of housing unemployment when
certain conditions like that exist the
likelihood of the abuse of children
happening
it's very likely the neglect and abuse
of children is undeniable
those facts were lost the importance of
the propaganda by the television
programs was to create a situation in
which the government could act to
control those communities you put up
pretty provocative signs in these
prescribed Aboriginal areas would you
put up the same signs here on the Gold
Coast in Queensland would you put those
signs up in places where there is child
abuse middle class Australia working
class Australia white Australia it's a
really good question because what you're
actually putting to and pointing to is
that we should not discriminate about
color but we should be actually
protecting children
let me tell you I live here on the
Sunshine Coast and there is Charlie it's
quite okay and right here there is no
doubt child sexual abuse it's not uh
exclusive right of one particular
ethnicity or one location
so in 2008 the central Australian group
of specialists put together a report
around the intervention
and I suppose one of the major things
that we
that we found and we wanted to make
clear to the government
was
was it after 11
health checks of children that had been
performed
there's only one child who was found
with a health condition that wasn't
Otherwise Known and that wasn't a
section assault case
so if if Mel Brook wants to dismiss this
report written by experts in their field
working on the ground
and I suppose you can but his dismissal
is false why did Gregory Andrews appear
anonymously this is a man who in effect
worked for you why did he appear on the
ABC's late line program calling himself
or them calling him an anonymous youth
worker why did that happen I don't know
why you would put the question to me
because I thought didn't he Brief you
before that no he didn't brief you no
the Parliamentary record tells a
different story
Broughton Parliament that Gregory
Andrews provided the information of his
notes to my office
[Music]
now the program used footage
showing Aboriginal children sniffing
petrol didn't it it did
they went from urijulu
the the petrol sniffing footage came
from a community called Docker river
which is hundreds of kilometers away but
it was represented as from
members of the matajulu community
complained to the ABC about the program
an inquiry confirmed that footage
claiming to be from matajulu had come
from elsewhere
disguising a government official as a
youth worker was called unfortunate
but Justified because he said he feared
for his safety the complaint was
rejected
the ABC declined my offer to be
interviewed for this film the people of
muttajulu and others complained to the
ABC
and an internal inquiry of a Kind was
held yes and which announced that the
program was exonerated what what's your
view of the process that exonerated the
program well I think it's uh it's
farcical really I mean it's a bit like
the police investigating their own
behavior it may be a perfectly proper
process internally to do that but then
to rely on it as exonerating the uh the
program makers seems to me to be going a
step much too far when this was exposed
did you get an apology from the ABC we
had no warning
no apology nothing and we I think we
left hanging in the air as though we're
still guilty one of the facts
that saddened uh the members of the
murugulo community
was a failure of the media
to recognize that the extremely lurid
allegations that had been made against
them were false and were found to be
false by the Australian crime commission
no one ever
uh took the time to clear the name and
the reputation of the murder Jeweler
Community again I say the Australian
crime commission which you gave special
powers to investigated and found no
evidence this is just simply incorrect
be completely
completely annihilated Us in what he did
that intervention was completely
disgustingly wrong I I certainly accept
that the intervention with wrong-headed
was stupid I said it at the time I
maintained that point it was based on a
deception wasn't it well more than that
it was based on a lie good
what was the LIE well the lie was that
basically to put it cut it short that
Aboriginal men were basically all child
molesters Aboriginal men I think are the
most demonized people in Australia and
I'm constantly saddened by that because
that's my father that's you know my
elders that's you know Aboriginal men I
I deal with every single day it saddens
me that they're painted as as these
rapists and people who can't control
themselves I think that's just
absolutely disgusting and it shows that
these people who write these things
don't know the Aboriginal men I know
they obviously haven't spent a lot of
time with Aboriginal people in
communities I think that's what really
saddens me because it affects Aboriginal
women as well because that's our that's
our husbands that's our sons that's our
uncles
um it's really disgusting and it is a
myth it's not true I mean we've got a
lot of racist policies in our past but
this one was the mother of them all and
in order to launch that policy the
federal government
with the assistance of the opposition
the labor party at the time suspended
the racial discrimination act in order
to bring it in and there is only one
reason why you suspend a racial
discrimination act and that is if you
intend to do something that's racist and
both parties admitted it was racist the
United Nations has branded it racist
but they did it anyway I'm damn sure if
so South Africa had proposed to
introduce similar legislation there that
would have been absolute outrage in the
rest of the world and yet here in
Australia we can do it get away with it
and nobody seems to think that there's
anything inherently wrong with it
that's the bit I don't get
what is the point of imposing something
like this on you I find it extremely
suspicious that you know I remember a
few years before the intervention was
placed in central Australia watching
huge
helicopters fly over our homeland in
with these massive big
I don't know what they were I can only
assume they were looking for minerals
and they just fly over it's like
watching a film from outer space these
helicopters flying over with this big
massive antenna-like things
hanging from them then you know a few
years later the government comes you
know crashing into the module Community
to crash to sort of obliterate these
pedophilia rings that actually weren't
there
and then they moved then they bring in
the intervention and it and then
amazingly they find this huge amount of
uranium and precious soils in central
Australia
and it all coincides around the same
time and I you know people might think
I'm being a bit paranoid
but you can't help but be paranoid when
all of those dots are sort of connecting
to each other
in 2007 a campaign called top end secret
2 was launched by the Northern Territory
government to explore for new mineral
deposits according to an industry survey
the Northern Territory is the New
Frontier of Australian mining
foreign
[Music]
it was here in Jay Creek the one Journey
ended for me and another began it was
1969.
my newspaper in London had sent me back
to discover my own country
how ironic
and I was in for a shock
this was a photograph I took at the time
Jay Creek was secret Australia
a government Reserve where people were
forced to live in unimaginable
conditions
[Music]
this was a holding cell
it was from places like Jay Creek the
children were taken in their thousands
by police and welfare officials
they became known as The Stolen
generation
[Music]
[Applause]
the policy was assimilation
it was influenced by the Eugenics
movement which had links to fascism
one official famously described it as
breeding out the black
it was genocide
Lorna feijo and her childhood friends
would hide in fear of being taken away
and I said be careful about taking brown
skin babies away from their mothers
black mothers
another black mother
so we used to go and we made a cubby
house down the creek
we dug a hole
and we used to practice and we used to
run then put when Aberdeen boy was
cockatoo what they call cockatoo
he had to watch yet and he had to cover
us up with leaves from the gum trees
and sure enough one day the horses came
Galloping and we ran down then we hid
they
we hid down in that Creek and that
Amazon boy was putting all the leaves
over us as if nothing happened and that
cracked the stock whip around him and he
thought he was frightened he put
panicking he ran back to the square camp
and the
welfare men found us and took us and
mothers were screaming and crying and
crying and hanging onto the truck when
the driver was away
oh yeah
your mother must have been she
threatened for me to the day she died
do you miss your mother a lot yeah
oh yeah cried nearly every night we all
used to cuddle up each other
[Laughter]
[Music]
known as The Bungalow
this is where many children were taken
from the 1920s to the 1950s where they
were easy prey for sexual predators
Australia's darkest secret is that rape
and sexual exploitation were used by
whites against black women
and children
today when Aboriginal people set this
history against the false claims that
led to the intervention
the irony is bitter
the time has now come for the nation to
turn a new page
a new page in Australia's history by
writing the wrongs of the past and so
moving forward with confidence to the
Future
we apologize for the laws and policies
of successive parliaments and
governments
that have inflicted profound grief
suffering and loss on these our fellow
Australians it was not an apology
on the murder the rapes the poisoning
and everything of Aboriginal Australia
or the First Nations as people prefer to
be known now
it was an apology
for stealing
so many
of our kids
with the same intention of assimilating
them
and making sure there is no continuity
of Aboriginal
traditional practices in Australia Mr
Rogers prime minister you broke a long
silence in Australia you apologize to
the Aboriginal people for the theft of
their children you said and I quote it's
not sentiment that makes history it's
our actions that make history what what
did you mean exactly
I think with the apology two things were
necessary one was a deeply
if you like spiritual or emotional
transaction between indigenous
Australians and non-indigenous
Australians
and that was simply but profoundly to
say sorry
it may sound
trite to some
I've heard it described as gesture
politics
but if you have deeply wronged people
or deeply wronged a person in your own
life
you cannot begin to conduct a normal
relationship until you've set wrongs to
rights at that level
but the wrongs did continue within a
year of rud's apology 37 Aboriginal
children were taken from their families
allegedly for neglect in the town of
lightning Ridge New South Wales
four days old
they just went to the hospital
mother's arms
down back in history this is what was
done with our little stolen generation
children
[Music]
a three-year campaign by the families in
lightning Ridge saw almost all their
children returned
but they're the lucky ones all over
Australia black children are being taken
from their homes many are given to
whites and lose all contact with their
Aboriginal families
this is a new stolen generation
it was actually only a fortnight ago I
received a call from community members
who are in distress who said that the
police and child protection agency had
actually turned up at a family's house
in the morning while the family was
having breakfast barged into the house
taken a three-year-old child put it in a
plane put it in a car and driven at 700
kilometers away from that community
the grandmother who was in that house
was wailing chasing the car throwing
rocks at the car and couldn't believe
saying over and over again that this is
what this is what was done to us before
when the stolen generation was at its
height this is this is happening again
in the north of Queensland almost 200
babies were removed
from their mothers in the hospital
it's an hours after giving birth these
babies are removed by the by the Child
Protection Services no explanation
about the process
why this has happened what their rights
are how they might be able to contest
this what they might be able to do left
crying left crying for their children
the author of this report Olga Haven was
sacked by the Northern Territory
government following its publication
the report revealed that in one year the
government spent almost 80 million
dollars on surveillance and removing
children compared with just five hundred
thousand dollars on supporting these
impoverished families
to 80 million dollars a year in action
and actually what what is called
Child Protection but these are the
people who take children that's right
take children away on the assumption
that there is child abuse across the
Aboriginal community in fact your report
shows that the Northern Territory where
the government aimed its guns
and described as the minister did child
abuse in Unthinkable numbers is among
the lowest in Australia that's correct
it's pretty sobering and I think the
other thing that's more than sobering
that's uh that's with all respect that's
some that's a major
deception
talking to people they tell me how much
they appreciated
your apology
but almost to a man and woman
they said nothing had changed in fact
many of them had said the situate said
the situation was worse I am not going
to send up here and sort of wave some
flag and say guess what
it's all fun and dandy haven't fixed it
okay I'm not into that look I've used
quite the Great Australian profits
that's [__] okay
it seems to me that the good news might
also fall into the category of [__]
why did you say
immediately I think after the apology
and you were very emphatic about this
in fact your words were I want to be
blunt about this there'll be no
compensation on the question of
compensation for injuries suffered
directly what I've said also to
Aboriginal leaders is that I don't rule
that out at all as a member of
parliament I just don't
Aboriginal people once more had their
expectations raised but what followed
was treachery that's the constant
pattern of black and white relations in
Australia raise the expectation and then
betray that trust with treachery
[Music]
this betrayal runs deep in Australian
political life with its connections to
powerful interests such as the mining
industry
[Music]
the Australian mining sector is
enormously profitable it makes profits
of around a billion dollars a week it
makes profits of of just under 52
billion dollars a year and it's a vast
amount of money
and what you basically have is large
companies making massive profits from
minerals that they didn't make on land
that they don't own
and that's called smart economics
that's called 21st century Australian
Economic Development
in the 1980s the labor party pledged
national land rights to the Aboriginal
people they call this Australia's
greatest moral cause
the mining Lobby went on the attack with
propaganda like this
through Aboriginal land claims your
right of access to up to 50 percent of
Western Australia could be taken away
you think it's fair that less than three
percent of our population should claim
ownership of up to 50 of our land
four-page newspaper ads
you thought it was your home
think again
targeting iconic
places in Australia a beautiful picture
of a beautiful place
have you loved this
take a good look now your kids mightn't
get a chance to
Aboriginal people will lock it up
white people won't won't be able to go
there you'll need permits to go to your
favorite Beach you won't be able to swim
or fish
at your favorite Beach because the
blacks will take it
it was extraordinary it was bald crude
and
sadly effective
once elected the government of Bob Hawk
gave in Universal land rights were
abandoned
in 2010 the mining industry spent 22
million dollars on a campaign to stop a
proposed tax on their super profits
what to all those who love Western
Australia say at that tax
[Applause]
ES
the campaign succeeded labor prime
minister Julia Gillard reduced the tax
to almost nothing
the revenue lost is estimated at 60
billion dollars
enough to fund land rights and to end
Aboriginal poverty
this is Robert eggington a warrior of
the nunga people of Western Australia
whose resistance defies a history of
dispossession
here he speaks uncompromisingly to a
white audience
I've experienced dark sarcasm and racism
from Authority since my early school
years to my adulthood
I don't believe in nationalism it's
offensive and it gives the false sense
of identity of those who have stolen
lands of which they now believe that
they so rightfully inherit
Robert has pursued those who denigrate
and exploit Aboriginal people
at a remarkable Healing Center in Perth
called dumbartung Robert and his wife
Selena celebrate Aboriginal culture and
history
and here they battle a modern disease
called suicide
they lost their own son Bob this way
I would say that within the last um
last two weeks here in Perth we would
have suffered and we would have
experienced seven to eight suicides
ranging from young children as young as
14 15 years of age the history of
colonization and What's led up to this
epidemic today is reflective of the
policies of the governments and in
particular the stolen Generations
certainly incarceration and the
continued incarceration of of young
Aboriginal men would be a key factor and
I think with a lot of young Aboriginal
men the loss of identity culture and
their Heritage plays a key role in the
sense of where their self-worth is
diminished and their value in a society
that doesn't value their culture or them
as even human beings for a lot of our
young people they don't see any hope at
the end or any light at the end of the
tunnel or any hope within their future
and so for many of them the answer is
not to want to be here anymore
Robert and Selena have made this a
memorial room
and covered it with photographs of
Aboriginal people and their families
all touched by lives cut short
all of the people to whom come here come
here to you know be able to emotionally
feel a sense of connection and belonging
they're able to and have a place where
they can just literally cry here
there's another photograph here of our
of our grandson
he's a very spirited little boy he lost
his dead
four years ago through suicide and this
very room here is a is a memorial is a
tribute to his dad our only son
it was like when our son died all our
hopes and dreams died with him but
that's not the case because here is our
beautiful little boy and this is where
we see our hopes and dreams now with our
little grandson as well as the other two
grandchildren that we have
we believe that when out comes our time
um to pass on we get we go back to the
Earth and we come part of that Earth
again so the cycles of of humanity and
Earth become one and uh and we're not
separated so you know if you've got a um
a belief system let's say like a western
belief system you going to be saved
outside of this world in a place called
Heaven well of course you can do with
this land as you like you can plunder it
pillage it rape it and destroy it it is
of no consequence but in our culture and
in our laws if we were to to to to harm
the land and to hurt that land the way
in which it's being done today we would
be punished spiritually very severely
for that
white Australia doesn't have a sense of
belonging to this land it only has a
sense of belonging to the establishments
and its institutions and its cities it's
built here it doesn't understand this
country
no more whispering in our minds
no more whispering in our arms
just Rise Up To Break These Chains
stop these killing games
foreign
[Music]
at Christmas
one less loved one on birthday
but that smile won't be forgotten
[Music]
can you never fail
in other Western countries indigenous
people still suffer but unlike Australia
historical treaties have been signed
that begin to recognize their right to
self-determination
Australia is the only developed country
repeatedly condemned for the abuse of
its indigenous people
now and then Australian government's
talk of reconciliation an acceptable
idea that hasn't built decent homes or
got rid of blindness in children and
malnutrition and dickensian diseases it
hasn't stopped young people suiciding
and it hasn't stopped a land grab that
began more than two centuries ago
like apartheid South Africa
reconciliation is not possible without
Justice and this will only happen when
the first Australians are offered a
genuine treaty that shares this rich
country its land its resources and
opportunities
the benefit then will be mutual
for until we give back their nationhood
we can never claim our own
no more whispering in our minds
no more whispering in our hearts
we're gonna rise up to Break These
Chains
stop these killing games
[Music]
so the night was blessed with evil
it has the soft rain became the full
[Music]
walking through the park at midnight
coastal town on the early morning
[Music]
shots rang out in the Darkness
Blood on the ground where you live
gonna rise up for you now
for the restore
[Music]
but no more whispering in our minds
no more whispering in our hearts
let's Rise Up To Break These Chains
stop these killings
we'll miss him for the game today
[Music]
when they run for the black and white
the colors of kaduga
hear those Mighty magpies
so let's all join the line of Honor
where's our glass to came
the son of a father
a child of a mother and a friend
[Music]
sisters and a brother
but no more whispering in our minds
[Music]
no more whispering in our hearts
let's Rise Up To Break These Chains
stop these killing games
[Music]